und der erste redner jetzt alexander
gauland fraktionschef der
bundeskanzlerin neben den üblichen
sozusagen chronischen problemen hat die
europäische union derzeit zwei akute
zwei wichtige länder beide an der
peripherie gelegen setzten sich auf weil
ich grund verschiedene art und weise von
der eu ab im nordwesten die briten im
südosten die türkei zu beiden müssen wir
unser politisches verhältnis neu
ausrichten und das war ja auch das
hauptthema ihrer rede
beginnen wir mit großbritannien meine
damen und herren es gibt ein leben nach
dem exit es gibt auch eine politik nach
dem break wir sollten also heute schon
dafür sorgen dass unsere beziehung zu
den briten keinen dauerhaften schaden
nehmen
sie bleiben ein politischer partner ein
wirtschaftlicher partner ein
militärischer partner und
selbstverständlich eine führende
europäische kulturnation dass das
politische gewicht der eu sind ohnehin
durch das ausscheiden der briten eine
atommacht eine flotte nation überdies
die zweitgrößte wirtschaftsmacht
verlässt den klub sorgen wir dafür dass
beide seiten sich gewogen werden
auch wenn es in diesem hause in den
medien in den zirkeln der globalisten
viel nicht passt der brh exit ist der
wunsch der mehrheit der briten es war
eine knappe mehrheit jahre doch diese
konstellation ist heute normal und
historisch bedeutende entscheidungen
sind gelegentlich auch durch knappe
mehrheiten herbeigeführt worden
wie ernst die älteste demokratie in
europa den mehrheitswillen im sehen wir
täglich ja die briten streiten erbittert
über den exit vor allem über den modus
des ausstiegs das in unserem konsens
süchtigen land vielleicht ungewöhnlich
aber das ist lebendige demokratie
vielleicht scheitert wo es johnson an
diesen streit aber das wäre ebenfalls
lebendige demokratie
auch wenn einige eu forme idealisten
noch von einem ausstieg aus dem ausstieg
träumen
großbritannien wird wieder ein
souveräner national statt
das ist nach ansicht der progressivsten
ein rückschritt ja ein rückfall in wie
es heißt längst überwundene zeiten
schließlich gehöre die zukunft
übernationalen post nationalen
strukturen
das sehen wir anders wir erhalten die
nationalstaaten nicht für überholt wir
glauben dass dieser planet ein blu ray
version bleibt und nun werden wir vor
der haustür einen direkten vergleich
haben welche seite mit ihrem politischen
system besser fährt
was will man also mehr es ist richtig
dass sich boris johnson in der nordland
frage entscheiden muss entweder in
nordirland wird auf eine bestimmte zeit
also bis es neue handelsverträge gibt
faktisch weiterhin eu recht gelten
dann kann die grenze offen bleiben oder
das eu-recht gilt dort wie im übrigen
teil großbritanniens nicht mehr dann
muss es grenzkontrollen geben beides
zugleich geht nicht allerdings darf die
dauer dieses übergangszeitraums nicht
einseitig von der eu festgelegt werden
soll muss von beiden partnern in
freundschaftlichen einvernehmen
gemeinsam gefunden wir frau
bundeskanzler hatte ich kann nur
wiederholen was ich hier schon gesagt
habe tun sie bitte alles ihnen mögliche
um den briten ihren abschied nicht zu
erschweren
für das leben nach dem wechsel
manche eurokraten betrachten den
britischen abgang freilich als einen
abriss tische kränkung das mag damit zu
tun haben dass sie selber an der
attraktivität der union zu zweifeln
beginnen eu bedeutet heute bürokratie
zentralismus zwischen geldentwertung
alimentierung von pleitestaaten
angekündigtes strafaktionen gegen die
osteuropäer weil sie die folgen der
deutschen masseneinwanderung politik
nicht mittragen wollen
der zweitwichtigste zahl steigt deshalb
aus norwegen und die schweiz zeigen
keinerlei interesse dem club beizutreten
und es geht ihm gut dabei estland hat
sein aufnahme aussuchen zurückgezogen
problematisch wird es wenn solche sich
solche kränkung 's gefühle mit
überlegenheit dünkel verein und in
offene geringschätzung münden
es ist ein bedrückendes phänomen dass
verschiedene ansichten in der
außenpolitik neuerdings dazu führen die
gegenseite als unzurechnungsfähig zu
behandeln begonnen hat es mit donald
trump derzeit ist boris johnson an der
reihe
wo bitte soll das hinführen wenn die
medien nicht ganz ohne beteiligung der
politik die regierungschefs von immerhin
verbündeten und mächtigen staaten als
clowns da schnell
[Applaus]
wo es im falle trump hinführt sehen wir
gerade in syrien der abzug der
us-truppen ist ein dann macht doch euren
kram alleine signal an die adresse der
europäer auf während die deutschen es
mit den militärischen
bündnisverpflichtungen nicht gar so
genau nehmen gerade auf der linken seite
des hauses rede die deutsche
öffentlichkeit seit zwei jahren über den
mächtigsten mann der welt welt wie über
einen ungezogenen studium das ist hybris
und der erfolg bekanntlich die nemesis
was ändert nichts daran dass auch für
den abzug der us-truppen für falsch
halten für einen verrat an den kurven am
bosporus sitzt ein präsident der von
einem neos manischen reicht räumt der
von der expansion des islam träumt der
seit langem schon über die türkische
minderheit druck auf die deutsche
politik auszuüben versucht die türkei
ist größer als die türkei sagte er in
einer rede und weiter wir können nicht
auf 780.000 quadratkilometern gefangenen
seien zugleich animiert er seine
landsleute bekanntlich fleißig kinder zu
zeugen und das türkische volk zu
vergrößern
unsere physischen grenzen sind anders
als die grenzen unserer herzen sagte
erdogan
in derselben rede und zielte auf unsere
brüder in mossul kirkuk masaka aleppo
haben's misrata skopje auf der krim und
im kaukasus berlin oder duisburg nannte
er einstweilen nicht
derzeit führt erbe an einen
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg auf
die kurdengebiete in ost syrien
der türkische präsident spekuliert über
eine vergrößerung des türkischen
territoriums und brot uns damit 3,5
millionen syrische flüchtlinge nach
europa durch zu lassen
wenn wir das zu kritisieren wagen unter
diesen flüchtlingen würden sich viele
erst terroristen befinden
die derzeit in großer zahl aus den
kurven kurdischen gefängnissen fliehen
womit können wir im gegenzug drohen wir
haben eine kaputte sparte bundeswehr und
sperrangelweit offene grenzen der
kurdisch türkische konflikt ist längst
auf unseren straßen angekommen
was macht die bundesregierung sie hat
erdogan dafür geld gegeben dass er
erledigt was wir angeblich nicht können
die grenzen schließen
wir haben uns von erdogan abhängig und
damit ab presber gemacht mit dem segen
der multikulturalisten lieben millionen
nichtdeutsche mit verfestigten
aufenthaltsstatus in unserem land unter
denen sich auch hunderttausende erdogan
anhänger befinden
wir können nicht wie der türkische
präsident mit flüchtlingsströmen drohen
etwa damit alle türken ohne deutschen
pass zurück zu schicken
denn wir sind ein rechtsstaat wir können
allerdings endlich damit anfangen aus
der situation zu lernen und unsere
grenzen zu schützen
nämlich zweierlei wenn wir lernen
zunächst einmal dass es töricht ist und
eines tages auch gefährlich werden kann
unentwegt menschen einwandern zu lassen
die unsere rechts- und werteordnung eben
nicht zu schätzen wissen und zu hoffen
dass sich das problem irgendwie schon
selbst von selbst lösen wird und
zweitens dass wir immer sagen wir müssen
unsere grenzen endlich wieder selber
schützen und meine damen und herren was
unsere bündnisse betrifft
die bundesregierung sollte darauf
drängen dass diese türkei unter dieser
regierung kein vollwertiges nagel
mitglied mehr sein kann
die nato muss die türkei mitgliedschaft
mindestens einfrieren und diese türkei
darf auch kein eu-mitglied werden
die eu muss den beitritt status aufheben
frau bundeskanzlerin und ich hoffe dass
sie sich für diese politik auch
einsetzen ich bedanke mich
[Applaus]